bonjour thomas c'est donc la première
fois que twitter et facebook supprime
carrément les messages du président pour
une autre raison qui n'atteint trop
droit d'auteur oui ce matin donald trump
ne peut plus utiliser ni son compte
facebook mais surtout son compte twitter
les modérateurs 2 et de ses réseaux
sociaux ont décidé de bloquer les
comptes du président des états unis
impossible pour lui de publier pendant
au moins douze heures sur twitter 24
heures sur facebook des messages avaient
déjà été supprimés dans la soirée car
jugée comme incitant à la violence selon
les modérateurs des plates formes il ya
notamment cette vidéo une allocution
enregistrée de donald trump qui a été
supprimé et qui est vraisemblablement la
raison de ces blocages par twitter et
facebook locataire de la maison blanche
il appelle ses soutiens à rentrer chez
eux mais continue d'affirmer que
l'élection il m'a été volé faisait
plusieurs mois que les géants du
numérique et les médias s'étaient
montrés très virulents contre le
président américain pour quel résultat
finalement mais chaque tweet ou presque
du président des états unis étaient
signalées par les modérateurs du réseau
social twitter notamment il faut se
souvenir que les patrons de ces
entreprises avaient indiqué m énormément
de moyens en oeuvre pour éviter toute
situation chaotique notamment au soir de
l'élection en novembre dernier ces
mesures ont finalement été appliqué hier
concernant les médias une grande partie
des médias américains a fait campagne
contre donald trump et de fait ils ont
également balayé les accusations du
président américain concernant cette
fraude qu'ils dénoncent depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines on a même
assisté à des scènes assez surréaliste
où des prises de paroles de donald trump
était interrompue en direct par des
présentateurs des grandes chaînes
américaines car il accusait locataire de
la maison blanche de divulguer de
fausses informations finalement cette
stratégie s'est sans doute avéré
contre-productif car les supporters de
trump l'ont perçu comme une forme de
censure contre leur président eux qui
allaient souvent choisi de voter pour
donald trump en opposition justement aux
élites médiatiques et politiques qui y
ont vu une nouvelle preuve de la
pertinence de leur candidat et vous
étiez à washington justement pendant l
élection américaine au mois de novembre
thomas vous avez même participé
et à ces manifestations des partisans de
donald trump quel était leur état
d'esprit qui est visiblement toujours le
en cours là aujourd'hui
oui alors cette manifestation était
juste après l'élection est déjà à
l'époque il reprenait les revendications
de donald trump sur ces éventuelles
irrégularités qui auraient pu peser sur
le scrutin alors à l'époque la
manifestation avait été globalement
pacifique mais j'avais déjà pu sentir
une très forte détermination chez un
certain nombre de participants à cette
manifestation une femme par exemple
m'avait expliqué qu'elle avait parcouru
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres pour
se rendre à washington pour cette
manifestation et qu'elle était prête en
ce qui la concerne à une guerre civile
ce sont ses mots alors évidemment tout
le monde au sein de cette manifestation
ne partagent pas les mêmes convictions
que cette femme mais ça montre bien
aussi la détermination qui peut habiter
chez une partie de les personnes qui
soutiennent encore donald trump
selon eux il estime agir pour une cause
juste en opposition justement aux médias
qu'il qualifie de médias mainstream
ainsi que les géants du numérique
d'ailleurs ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à se détourner de ses chaînes
traditionnelles et même là
traditionnellement conservatrice fox
news ne trouve plus grâce à leurs yeux
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup thomas pour cet éclairage